it's the largest demonstration staged by
this Trade union organization since
before the pandemic helping to swell the
numbers has been a change in South
Korea's government to a conservative
Administration seen as pro-business and
not as friendly to workers there's the
possibility of increasing the number of
hours in the working week but what trade
unionists are fearing the most is
spiraling inflation they say their wages
can't keep Pace with
our biggest problem is inflation I know
it's a global issue and it's caused by
War but why should the consequences of
it be passed all the way down to us
workers
extending the working hours doesn't make
sense even the current 42 hours that I
work there isn't enough time for my kids
and my family life suffers
Rising fuel costs led to a national
strike by truck drivers last month that
caused supply chain disruption affecting
production in South Korean factories and
Rising prices are causing changes in
people's everyday habits with more
workers making do with convenient store
meals for lunch
prices at my usual restaurant went up so
now I come here instead about two or
three times a week
there's more pain on the way for
consumers and Home Buyers
Real purchasing power is shrinking in
the face of fierce inflation secondly
interest rates are on the rise
simultaneously which is a burden for
people paying off loans the March ended
at the offices of South Korea's
president in the hopes this new
Administration will hear workers
grievances the workers had been pushing
for an increase in the minimum wage of
nearly 20 percent but after a lot of
negotiations have had to settle for just
five percent which they are far from
happy with and the government has been
urging companies to limit wage Rises
across the board to curb inflation in
South Korea right now there's plenty to
fuel workers anger Rob McBride Al
Jazeera Seoul